when you come to a crisis that's when
people reveal themselves to be who they
truly are and we saw that during the
pandemic the people who not only rushed
to put the government in control of
things to in many ways disregard the
state and federal constitutions you know
the Constitution doesn't have a clause
for an emergency it's there no matter
what and there are a lot of people
trampled all over that thinking oh it's
an emergency it's emergency no that's
exactly why you have a constitution is
so that uh so you know self-proclaimed
emergencies don't take the day that's
what you have in dictatorships and
oppressive regimes around the world we
don't have that in the United States we
should never forget that we should never
allow something like this uh to happen
again
foreign
Rubin and joining me today is the 45th
governor of the great state of Wisconsin
and currently the president of Young
Americans Foundation Scott Walker
welcome back to the Reuben report
great to be back thanks for having me
Allen I'm glad to talk to you today
because we are only a few days out from
these very strange midterm elections uh
strange do you like my adjective Choice
there or do you have a better one
I do no I'm with you on strange I think
you're right it's not it's not bad it's
not good it's just strange it's a great
way to say it what do you what's your
takeaway I mean you know everyone said
this Red Wave was a comment I kind of
was saying it myself but I kept saying
you know you can't count your chickens
before they hatch and all that stuff and
obviously we still have a couple races
that haven't been announced as of us
taping this right now but but what's
your main takeaway
well a couple different things it's not
as big of a win for Republicans as many
people thought but taking the house at a
minimum if that's where we end up being
I think is a good thing because it
obviously slows the horrendous horrific
and almost existential threat that we
have out of Washington uh with the bite
Administration is lackey's there so if
for nothing else if there's at least
enough votes uh to make some other than
Nancy Pelosi the speaker that's a good
thing to counter things I think one of
the big takeaways though I took out of
Tuesday was uh that ideas matter and
that it's not enough just to say you're
against Joe Biden the polls
overwhelmingly show dissatisfaction with
the way Joe Biden's acting the way
they're handling the accounting or not
handling it so I think unfortunately a
lot of candidates on the right thought
well we just we'll talk about how bad
Biden is and we'll just run as not being
Biden and I'm voters wanted more uh and
to prove that case I would tell you that
where there were big wins is every
incumbent Republican governor in the
country not only one in their
re-elections they won big and in many
cases saved some of the Senate
candidates Ohio's a prime example JD
Vance may not have won that race if it
had been for Mike dewine win them like
big time Herschel Walker might not have
been in a runoff in this Georgia Senate
race had Brian KIPP not win going away
and you know other governors sunodu in a
Battleground state where unfortunately
we didn't get as close as we thought New
Hampshire won big there Kim Reynolds in
Iowa and obviously the two big ones Ron
DeSantis in Florida and Greg Abbott in
Texas I mean the big winners on Tuesday
were Republican governors in large part
because they didn't just talk about
Biden they actually talked about how to
lead and they acted on him were you
surprised that there were wasn't more
anger to some of kind of the the
Democrat quote-unquote stars of the
pandemic I mean a Gretchen Whitmer who
had some of the worst lockdowns and
hypocritical moves in her personal life
during it or you know it's not like
Gavin Newsom is going to lose but you
know him in California or even Hotel in
New York who nobody voted for first time
around because she obviously came in
after Cuomo was taken out but that they
didn't pay any price really
no I I was surprised uh in that regard I
think particularly in Michigan because
we all still kind of hoped that that was
a Battleground State I think after
Tuesday not just the governor's race but
you look at the even the Regent
positions in the University system I
mean it has sadly become a sadly Blue
State in Michigan almost the flip side
of Ohio which used to be a Battleground
State and it's pretty consistent with
Republican now
although you look at other Governors I
mean the Democrat Governor in Colorado
who I disagree with on other issues was
arguably one of the better ones when it
came to the lockdowns and he got
rewarded with a huge win there so yeah
polis did for sure and and I think
obviously the big winners of Florida and
Texas are good examples of people who
and I would say just governors in
general not just DeSantis and Abbott but
they were the most visible ones and
remember the tractors said oh people are
going to die they had a guy dressed up
as a grim reaper on the beaches in in
Florida in uh Beto said oh people are
going to be dead because of Greg Abbott
no they got their states open they only
got their economy back on track their
kids if you look at the scores are doing
arguably much better than kids in states
that were shut down but sadly Michigan
New York and California are probably now
in the foreseeable future pretty solid
blue States and people there even though
the facts are right in front of them
apparently at least in these elections
weren't willing to budge from that
do you miss any of the of the game
obviously two-time Governor you ran for
president you know now you're you're
doing your thing with Young Americans
but do you miss the fights I mean when
it's election night or you're like ah I
should have got back in or I should be
doing this or that
my wife was actually all excited about
that she used to hate those nights when
I was a candidate she was all excited
about it Tuesday I'm like who are you
what have you done to my wife uh but uh
I don't actually I don't miss the
campaign stuff the election night the
nerves uh certainly when I saw some of
the tv ads in Wisconsin and elsewhere
across the country I don't miss that one
of the things I always felt I would miss
and I do are some of the people although
I'm blessed at Young America's
Foundation to bump into not only in my
state Wisconsin but across the country
some of the same sorts of folks and
obviously being with these Brave heroic
high school college and now middle
school students who are trying to stand
out on their campuses and schools as
conservatives is very rewarding I think
the biggest thing I I found during covet
people said to me oh it must be nice not
to be governor and that was my initial
reaction but after a couple months of
fools across the country in my state and
elsewhere locking things down as you can
imagine it I just looked and said we
could be doing so much better people
always ask me what would I have done I
look at not only DeSantis and Abbott but
Christy gnome is another example in
South Dakota it said I would have put my
trust in the people give people
information let them know what the uh
what the circumstances are but have your
put enough faith in the American people
and the people in each state to let them
make the right decisions for themselves
their families their children uh
Governors and and for that matter Mayors
and others who did that and their
jurisdictions are doing far better than
those that lock things down I don't know
if you happen to see it but there was an
article a couple weeks ago in the
Atlantic about pandemic amnesty did you
happen to catch that or see any of The
Firestorm around that
I I did a little bit I didn't read the
article but I I did I did see that uh so
so broadly the idea that all that 2020.
yeah so the idea of asking this idea
that we should just sort of forgive
everybody who did all of these you know
massive government overreach things and
that we let bureaucrats trample on the
Constitution and all these things I
suspect from a Yale studio uh you're not
really in the mood for amnesty
no and and I think it's as you and I
know uh sometimes not only in politics
but in life in general when when you
come to a crisis that's when people
reveal themselves to be who they truly
are and we saw that during the pandemic
the people who not only rushed to put
the government control of things to in
many ways disregard the state and
federal constitutions you know the
Constitution doesn't have a clause for
an emergency it's there no matter what
and there are a lot of people trampled
all over that thinking oh it's an
emergency it's emergency no that's
exactly why you have a constitution is
so that uh so you know self-proclaimed
emergencies don't take the day that's
what you have in dictatorships and
oppressive regimes around the world we
don't have that in the United States we
should never forget that we should never
allow something like this uh to happen
again and again if you look back
hindsight's always 20 20 but I think
it's very instructive to see the the
governors the Mayors the other officials
who again put their faith in taking
their shoes say I I never once thought
it wasn't a serious issue but who put
their faith in the people I have one of
the big takeaways and I think you have
seen this in some of the exit polling
was I I think post-pandemic there is a
shift it's less about conservative and
and liberal Democrat Republican as it
was post-pandemic about blue collar and
white collar jobs I think a lot of
people like my brother who's a manager
at a convenience store in Chained and my
sister-in-law who sells appliances for
Home Depot great good hard-working
people they and other blue collar
workers like them I think became very
turned off towards the the heavy hand of
the government because first it was
their the place they worked at and then
it was their kids schools both of which
they were upset were closed versus sadly
in the suburbs in particular a lot of
white-collar employees who were like I
don't have to commute to work my kids
can each hang out in their bedrooms be
on their on their uh computers all day
in school we spend more time together
this isn't so bad and they were the ones
that kind of bought into giving these
freedoms away I think there's going to
be a long-term shift that reflects a
more severeign voter salary being open
to government control and more blue
collar workers on their families who are
like I don't ever want this to happen
again if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell